hello everybody my name is markiplier
[Laughter]
sorry
oh god sorry sorry the nicest car here
and you [ __ ] well not anymore
oh god sorry sorry sorry sorry
so I remember that hello chopper for me
before cedar baby
alright I'm hopping out don't kill me I
will try whoever's in the passenger seat
this has a gun on the front
I don't know how surveillance cameras
there are versions of this helicopter
that have a gun if we get a military
helicopter oh yeah exactly there we go
should we get should we go to that Wow
my helicopters really wobbly should we
go to the airport and get another
helicopter and then assault a military
base to others to antutu on to and then
all sing grided Valkyries together as we
assault can we leave wade in a
helicopter by himself because he kind of
small that's Jack's fault for sweating
on my seats come in for a landing
I wanna I want to land at full speed
right good strategy is that the strategy
okay I'm not gonna crash I'm an
excellent flyer look like worried crash
I'm like great shut up
yep yep yep that's my car don't destroy
hilariously
now how do I go up
alright so W a s and D are W and s are
up and down a and D are like tilt left
and right and then numpad eight four
five six
it's like another WASD and that's tilt
forward and MA yeah I told you I don't
you should just get an Xbox one
controller and plug it in because holy
[ __ ] you're gonna have trouble good
helicopter just spawn - I'm gonna deal
with give this bad boy Wade you almost
killed me I wouldn't have a nice board
period what we should have a who's got
the biggest helicopter competition where
we're actually I just picked it up on
the helicopter pad I'm gonna pick my car
up - I'll bring that with us lead us off
with the ride of the valkyries
[Laughter]
flip-flopping around it's not working
you gotta go fast
I gotta go forwards okay for ten cooter
cooter I'm way down Oh you because I'm
trying to go as fast as you can but I
can't no no I'm turning around waiting
for Bob I'm being nice
Bob slow she are so in case anything
goes down this cars like extra bonus car
I can already see like the flash forward
that's not gonna work this car me when
they start shooting rockets at the
helicopters I can't see okay I see one
person who's in front of me it's jack up
there okay Jack you and Jack are up in
the front
okay I'm we're coming up in the middle
ish just where you like it [ __ ] oh I
don't know what that means no wait no
one thought that no not a single person
thought that I think my car's weighing
me down what are we doing jets that's
all that happens whenever we play this
why why not see you don't know what else
to do hey wait oh oh oh you get stars
immediately oh okay touch and go
touching go you know they basically
impossible to duck oh sweet I'll come
get you fine I'm just gonna steal a car
and do it the old-fashioned way
Jack you have to punch it first and then
why I kicked it but it's all good all
right okay I'm very far from my jet
there's boss Oh God oh my god I just I
got to get a car wake me up pick me up
bro god damn it Wade I was trying to get
in with your car laid this is only to
choose later yeah damn yeah go to hell
why do I keep getting sent notification
hell yeah yeah I keep getting ot mo you
cops Dane is here you guys I have no
idea how to turn that off that just
happens okay one of the many find menu
features of he's still mad yes still mad
you shot at me use this is bull you want
finish it you're finished oh yeah finish
it what was I saying oh my god Jesus
yeah we do that a lot
yeah there you Jack you Sol God what
what Bob said Sol god I said so Oh God
oh they said Sol god it's not working as
I had to plant here we go Jack fire more
missiles at trying to kill off guys what
did we do yeah to be fair Jack you're
really not trying to kill us that
you're mostly trying to kill Wade right
now I fired one at you guys but yeah
everything don't come over here
yeah not not this way
no oh god okay apparently this way Billy
I'm bailing ah why did I fall
Thanks kill you can we steal a tank is
there a tank to steal no explosion yeah
did anyone need a pickup in my police
car I bet you guys I will get a jet
again before you do Sherlock oh you want
the table take it up I'll take it up I
bet I get the jet are you confident
enough to take it up oh god yes forget a
jet before you do I bet one of us
looking at stories have you guys one of
us okay oh you gotta be pretty confident
jack well Wade's not getting one
probably not getting one either I'm
about to get murdered by some crazy-ass
cops
Oh God
upside-down car is bad okay stealing
jets this is fun Jerry in this game I've
never tried why can't I break a fence
I got shot in the face
this is bunch of [ __ ] I'm so pretty
good I'm so okay wait I need a ride
where are you if nobody gets a jet
that's my question
wait wait right here wait don't you dare
wait no wait no wait oh God [ __ ] I'm
already being shot at just so you know
oh god damn it
oh it's way too mature Oh ease no no
he's at he's in a car I got a car lose
the cops
thank you just aim I'm aware that that's
a thing I should do how do I get a gun
wheel where's my gun wheels don't want
the cops to chase you let's remember
okay is it tab
oh I press Z naught F oh wait wait wait
thank you wait your your dear I love you
machines look right behind you already
be a nice glowy on the way you don't
have enough momentum to get up the hill
wait push you guys wait wait wait thanks
thanks thanks thanks thanks thanks
thanks thanks thanks wait you're the
left side there's a road up the left
side your dick is there yeah got him
Amir SUV come here
what a bunch of dicks stop you [ __ ]
wait wait what are you doing Oh Jackson
the road over there we have no back
tires you guys are about to lose this
bet by the way no we're not no way in
there you can't get in there from the
middle what are you doing wait stop Oh
excuses come on yes I ain't even mad I
ain't even mad bro
why the jet so once I get to it I don't
know what I'm gonna my god I got it I'm
coming up the hill oh I'll just wait
right here don't worry
all right
[Music]